you've been in quite a few horror films
are you a fan of them yourself i'm a
hater i try not to hate i'm a hater i'm
a hater of horror films
hi i'm jamie lee curtis i am going to be
answering questions for lad bible right
now
what advice would you give your younger
self
lighten the f up
what's the best memento you've kept from
a movie
i collect the slates the the what they
call they used to call them clapper
boards
um i have a collection from every movie
i've ever been in including the original
halloween movie slate which was a porn
slate
that dean cundy had used for all the
porn films that he shot as a young dp
and i waited around until the final shot
of the movie and asked him if i could
keep it and since then i have collected
slates from
all of
the
um movies that i have done
what is one item you couldn't live
without and why
it's called a bandolier
um it is a phone case
that hangs and you wear it
across your body
and it allows you
your phone and a wallet
and it is the greatest invention since
velcro
i've probably bought hundreds of them
i've given them as gifts more times than
i can ever tell you
you've been in quite a few horror films
are you a fan of them yourself
not
likely
no i am i'm the opposite of a fan of
them i am a what is the opposite of a
fan i'm a hater i try not to hate i'm a
hater i'm a hater of horror films
describe to me your ideal first date do
you know how i met my husband
no
i saw his picture in a magazine and said
i was gonna marry him
i went out to dinner with my friend
melanie griffith and her then husband
steve bauer we sat down chris was facing
me two tables away
and then five minutes later he got up to
leave and he stood there next to his
journey went like this
and i went
and he left but he called me the next
day and we got married four months later
what was your biggest star struck moment
i
[Music]
went to the women's march in los angeles
on
january 20th 2017.
and
i knew i was going to speak and then
they started running late and it started
getting long and i kept saying to them i
don't need to speak i don't need to
speak and then they said okay but will
you introduce helen reddy
and i was like
you want me to introduce little already
i just like i couldn't speak and then
she sings i am woman
and i'm singing i am woman on stage with
helen reddy at the women's march in los
angeles
it's been a freaky friday and it's super
fun
if you're a dog what breed of dog would
you be in why
um
i'd be a i'd be a
bit sir i'd be a [ __ ] to this in a bit
so that
the mongol like a bit of everything i
think
all right these dogs are gonna get
really fat and we will have to like
rehouse them as walruses